what do you think happens after we die
having come close to that
that um that cliff
and almost got pushed over once
what do you think happens when you do
get pushed off the cliff
okay i feel dumb that i'm even gonna
like preface this by saying obviously i
have no [ __ ] idea and i think that's
one of the cool things about death no
idea the cia probably does you think the
cia
i love like we've decided your audience
is the cia yeah
how would you oh wait i i need to
because there's a lot of suspicion that
i might be fsb and mossad so i'm trying
to rebrand
i'm trying to steer them into the cia
direction no as far as what happens when
you when you die
one thing i return to when i'm getting
overly complex
is the idea of as above so below
so uh that you can a lot of the big
questions can be answered by your own
experience
now
so
in other words like uh
in terms of thinking about like death
um
if you look back to
baby legs
versus adult legs
where's the baby like baby's gone they
you've regenerated all your cells
many times by then so
in a way you could say
lex baby died and the death didn't look
like a typical
and i'm not trying to dodge it but i'm
just saying it was very natural that the
death of that baby it just uh
it just in many ways that baby died but
i am at least personally i'm surprised
how much the person is exactly the same
so there's many ways in which you're
very different
but there's a lot of ways in which
you're very much the same sure and i
wonder
if that
if there's if life is defined by many
deaths that contin that continue on and
then there i wonder if something
persists sure beyond in this
that
yeah there is something that still
persists i wonder okay so that
now
you know obviously
there's so many different
answers to this question that are
religious and
ranging from like the most absurd [ __ ]
you ever heard in your life like the
gold
you're going to get a mansion there's
gold streets like i don't know do you
even want like gold streets like offers
gold streets i know about the virgins
but there's a bunch of virgins the
christians give you the gold streets in
the mansion like depending on the
and the who whatever the particular sect
of christianity is you know you you it's
like it's some kind of city there's
it's like paved with gold no one's
addressing the fact that the moment the
streets are made of gold gold is a
valueless
substance i mean it's sort of pretty in
a cheesy kind of way but no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] it's like like if there was
not a lot of
uh asphalt in the world
then you know we'd be in heaven from
that same with that way of thinking but
the
uh or honestly when uh going back this
this this is starting to get a theme
with glug archipelago i'm sorry i'm
reading it currently that's a sticky
book yeah it's very sticky in your mind
very very tough as i'm running through
very hot heat i'm listening to glug
archipelago oh my god and you know one
of the things they said they would feed
the prisoners salt
um
and then they would exchange
the prisoners would be able to
give up anything everything their gold
their possessions everything for just
one drink of water so that little
context of
uh dehydrating them and feeding them
salt changes your value system
completely right so maybe the gold is
supposed to be a metaphor for something
that you still value deeply yes it's
yeah again any any of these things when
you like take them literally they seem
absurd but if you look deeper into it
it's like quite beautiful but the
buddhist version of it is that uh
there's a momentum the best way to put
it is it's a kind of momentum so
uh the thing you're talking about which
is
uh the personality of the baby that is
still in the adult which is still in the
old person you're looking at a kind of
momentum that does not stop
upon the
extinction of the body
now
the
there's i think there's a lot of uh
i don't want to say harm because they
didn't mean to hurt but i think there's
some harm that maybe has happened from
the way death
is represented in movies like when
people die in movies it's like
there's this usually it's pretty fast
even if it is uh
what they're dying from is a long-term
disease it like wraps up pretty quickly
starts with a cough the person's in bed
but there's this weird kind of lucidity
to the person up until the point of
death and also they generally in movies
they have makeup on which is always
funny to me when the person dying looks
great if you're ever around a dying
person
they're dying they look like [ __ ] you're
dying they're all gray and like confused
they're
you know when you're around dying people
they will spin through time
your parents won't recognize you for a
second they'll think you're somebody
else they won't they're like
everything's
everything's like the process is
happening so
it's a you're very confused when you die
so
in general not all the time some people
die with a with a clear mind it just
depends on the type of death but
think in terms of
uh getting hit by a car so you want to
cross the street you get hit by a car
now
if we're talking about this momentum
continuing
the confusion assuming you didn't hit
your head and you're unconscious like
somehow you just got smashed and you're
like bleeding out
even then you're going to be confused
because you're getting dizzy like
blood's leaving your body you're like
things are fading out your vision's
going so it's a very confusing
experience initially when the body dies
if you are a
materialist
who has been
who has convinced themselves that
it's a permanent thing
the next bit of confusion is going to be
when you realize
something is persisting here like i'm
still here and this is where you run
into the near-death experiences which
are a global phenomena that don't seem
to be
completely shaped by culture
you know like regardless of what part of
the world people are having these
experiences in the reports tend to be
similar and everyone's heard it the
light the life review
uh
seeing ancestors and stuff like that
now i don't know what that is
i
don't know i i
sometimes i think that's probably just
like a built-in
way the computer shuts down you know
just this is something it does who knows
but
uh
in buddhism the concept is
this momentum persists into something
called the bardo the bardo means in
between and um
there's an actual number of days they
say that it you get to hang out there
and i can't remember it's like 37 days
or 29 days or something i'm not sure but
at least from the
time space perspective that's how long
they're there
within this
place uh
it's there are a lot of technological
parallels man it's like
in the way the algorithm
is reflective it assesses your desires
or whatever and then produces something
that is
has within it a component of attraction
to you apparently this happens in the
bardo like or the way you know you wake
up in the morning
and
you're in a shitty mood
and then coincidentally everyone that
day is an [ __ ] if you don't catch it
you could just be like wow i guess it's
act like an [ __ ] day you don't
realize you're seeing your
[ __ ] projection
like being reflected off the screen of
another person so in the bardo
apparently you don't need people for the
reflective quality
these projections happen and they're
they appear as either
nietzsche's demon or nietzsche's angel
it just depends on
where you're at and how you died and
like if you died scared
then at least initially that's going to
be some scary [ __ ] you see around you if
you died in a peaceful way well then
there's going to be more of a
possibility of navigation through this
liminal intermediary
place
and so thus the emphasis on meditation
and buddhism a way to
calm one's self to not be distracted by
thoughts which are their own like
apparitions
and then
theoretically if you wanted to
instead of
spinning the wheel again
and jumping back into a body
you could choose not to do that and then
you know transcend the wheel of birth
and death but
if you still wanted to go back
or
return or whatever however you want to
put it then you could have more control
over what your next birth might be
versus
in this depiction of things people
running from
demons that they don't recognize as
their own projection
into
any [ __ ] body that they can find
because if you've had a body you want a
body and so this is how you could
incarnate as an animal this is how you
get incarnate in the hell realms this is
how you could incarnate in any variety
of things but the idea is like maybe you
could slow down
a little bit and like choose a birth
that is going to be more conducive
to you
uh
continuing to like
spiritually evolve i like that idea is
it true or not who the [ __ ]
algorithmically speaking it it seems
like a really fun role-playing game
where you basically oh yeah keep
improving the different parameters
based on your
ability and willingness to
meditate and
let go of the
of the
menial concerns of life on earth
you